excellent let's have a look at some of
these definitions now by the way
i think this is really cool when i was
walking around pretty much
no one had exactly the same sentence
even though you all
mostly had a sentence some more helpful
than others
but this idea of symmetry it's very
common it's not just common to
young people but it's actually a really
important idea in the study
of beauty right they say there's there's
studies actually out there which say
that things which are symmetrical
are things which we view as beautiful
and in fact you know when you say oh
someone's really good looking
uh one of the things the qualities that
they say a good looking people have
is that their faces are very symmetrical
and when a face is not quite symmetrical
we can't put our finger on it but we say
ah yeah
it's yeah sorry buddy you know not the
most beautiful thing so
symmetry is a super important idea and
it's really really profound let's have a
look at some of these ideas
um when you have the shape and both
sides are equal
hmm okay so the idea is you've got a
you've got a shape like this or
something like that
okay like this and if you chop it in
half
both sides are equal so if i sliced it
like this
then you've got this side and this side
and they're kind of well not in mine but
they're meant to be equal all right
i think that's a good idea let's keep
going a shape has symmetry when
it reflects on the other side of the
symmetry line okay hold on hold on
lots of words here who's is this one
again this is it's not down there
okay so if i come back to this diagram i
guess we would call the symmetry line
a bit like the line that you use to have
the shape right this guy
he seems important okay and it reflects
on the other side
and you get the exact same on both sides
so it's like a mirror okay
so it's like it's like this triangle
over here
is looking at a mirror and this is what
the reflection looks like okay cool
a shape of symmetry when you can draw
one or more lines through the aha
in the center that's a different idea
and all parts
are equal okay where would the center of
this shape be
maybe somewhere like this okay so you
gotta
draw a line through it last one you put
a line through the middle of the shape
okay that's again getting the same idea
the other side is reflected okay
i think these are all really good
they're all getting at the idea they're
all correct
i want to give us a little more def
detailed definition and
i want to connect it to what we looked
at over the past couple of days right
what have we looked at under geometry
what were the first things we looked at
do you know what they're called yep yeah
translation and reflection and rotation
and all of those together they're called
long phrases transformations that's
right okay
so i'm going to write a definition for
you that's in terms of those
and i want you to copy down and we'll
discuss it okay so here we go here's my
definition
i'm going to shape her symmetry if
you can
transform it and get back
exactly the same shape
in exactly the same place okay
let's unpack this okay now we know what
the transformations are
okay so if you take one of the
transformations let's take reflection
okay if i apply it to this shape here
right
i think there's a straight line that i
can run through this
so that if i apply the transformation i
just get back
the same shape in the same place that's
really important
okay so if i take my triangle again
right
and now the instructions i gave you were
reflect this triangle
you know this would be a uh b and
c okay and i gave you a straight line
now before
we looked at straight lines which are
like over here and over here and outside
the shape
but if i draw this line through the
shape just like i had before
i draw a line through like that what
will happen now this is actually
important that you draw the shape with
me
because go through the process of
reflection okay for instance
a look at a when i reflect it's going to
become a new point before we call it a1
where will a1 be
where's it gonna go
if i do the same way that i do
reflection before i go this distance
right and then i look at the opposite
side of the line in the same
length right so my new copy of a
a1 is going to be over here on top of b
in exactly the same way b is going to
reflect across the line and become b1
over here okay where does c go when you
reflect it
c doesn't go anywhere right because it's
on the line of reflection
okay so c and c1 are on the same spot
okay so now our shape well
the points the corners are in a
different order right they're sort of
back to front this way
but it's the same shape in the same
place
so we say this shape has symmetry okay
now hold on stay with me
um i said if you can transform it right
but we know there is more than one kind
of transformation you already told them
to me this translation
and reflection and rotation
so this symmetry here which we got from
reflection is one kind
right you can you can reflect
but you can also rotate a shape and get
a transformation right
so for instance can you think of a shape
so that if you rotate it in some way
you'll get back exactly the same shape
in exactly the same
place yeah a circle great
if i draw a circle like this right
and i say look let's rotate it about the
point
and i pick this point in here right at
the middle of the circle okay
well how do you rotate something around
okay you take a few points
like maybe we'll call that one a and b
and c maybe right and if we rotate it
around for instance if i go around like
this
let's go this number of degrees however
far that is
okay so this line is going to go there
this line is going to go there so now
i've got a1 and
b1 and c1 okay but when i draw the
circle that goes through all these new
points
it's the same circle i had before it's
the same shape
in the same place okay now this is a
kind of symmetry as well
we call this one reflection or symmetry
or
line symmetry that's an important kind
of phrase you want to put that down
reflectional or line
symmetry why do you think it's called
mind symmetry
because when you're reflecting yeah yeah
the line is the piece that tells you
where you do your transformation
and in the same way this is called
rotational symmetry
now just like this is line symmetry what
do you think we might call this as well
as
rotational symmetry it's not a line that
we're
rotating around it's a it's a point
so we also call this point symmetry
okay now these kinds of symmetry are
really cool
we're going to explore them in a little
more depth today we're just going to
look at this one
next time we'll look at this on friday
okay so
here's what we're going to do um
we're going to get some pieces of paper
out okay
now i'm going to ask you to create some
symmetrical shapes with these pieces of
paper and some scissors here's the way
you're going to do it
okay um on your piece of paper right
now what you're going to do is you're
going to fold it
okay now this is really important once
you fold it okay
there's now a line down the middle of my
paper okay
a line like this
line is really important this line that
i'm reflecting across
that everyone's been talking about here
you know middle center all that kind of
thing it's so important
it gets its own name it's called
the axis of symmetry
okay now here's the important thing
right
shapes well some shapes are not
symmetrical at all right here's my pair
of scissors
my pair of scissors is not symmetrical
okay there is no
line that you can draw through it such
that if you reflect it
you get the same shape in the same place
so some
shapes have no axis of symmetry
some shapes have one axis of symmetry
okay
and still others will have lots of
different and there's uh there's a
plural work
lots of different axes of symmetry
okay so get this axis axis that's the
singular
that's when you've just got one okay you
can have one axis
but if you've got lots if you can draw
lots of different lines and reflect
across and get
the same shape in the same place you
have
many axes of symmetry
okay singular plural now
once you do that okay you're gonna draw
your cut your line
across here sorry fold your line okay
and then i want you to cut a shape
okay now here's the cool thing if you
cut
across this line any shape you like okay
for instance i might cut this
let's see if i can do this
okay so i've cut a shape out right but
when i unfold it i should get
a symmetrical shape thank you okay oh
you're welcome
it wasn't for you now what you've got
there is a symmetrical shape okay
um we're going to do this a couple times
for everyone you can do some interesting
shapes
right um here's here's one there you go
you can see that right and you can see
there's the axis of symmetry
okay but you can do the interesting
thing that's it boy it's a bit straight
you could do something
like this this is still symmetrical
and you can just see barely see the
folds
you can even do some shapes that are
disconnected okay so you can see if i do
this way
okay there's the axis of symmetry
depending on what you cut
okay so here's the way we're going to do
it